[Aplausos]
[Música]
la respuesta de los aliados a la
invasión rusa de Ucrania ha sido muy
clara por un lado han apoyado al
gobierno de zelensky con toneladas de
armas y dinero por otro han castigado a
Rusia con un montón de sanciones
económicas de todo tipo desde la
prohibición de que los barcos y los
aviones rusos usen los puertos y
aeropuertos occidentales hasta la
prohibición de suministrarles un montón
de productos de todo tipo hablamos de
uno de los programas de sanciones más
grandes jamás llevados a cabo os hemos
hablado de yo tanto en el boletín de
patrón como en pasados vídeos El caso es
que el apoyo a Ucrania ha sido todo un
éxito el gobierno ucraniano ha
conseguido resistir la embestida rusa e
incluso darle la vuelta a la tortilla y
tomar la iniciativa Pero qué ha ocurrido
con la segunda parte de la respuesta
occidental que está ocurriendo con las
sanciones a Rusia hasta juntos han
debilitado la economía de este país
están siendo un éxito o un fracaso
bien teniendo en cuenta todas las
sanciones rápidamente se creó una
expectativa que la economía rusa se
vendría abajo y el país colapsaría sin
embargo terminado el 2022 situación
parecía muy diferente Sí el país entró
en recesión pero apenas se dejó un dos y
medio por ciento y lo que es aún peor
los ingresos del gobierno ni siquiera se
resintieron de hecho pese a todas las
sanciones en 2022 los ingresos de Rusia
por la exportación de hidrocarburos se
dispararon fijaos los ingresos de Rusia
por las ventas de petróleo aumentaron
casi un tercio durante el año por
ejemplo las exportaciones de gas cayeron
pero Rusia exportó más petróleo y más
gas natural licuado que los años
anteriores Y además todo lo vendió a
precios mucho más altos lejos de hacerle
hincar la rodilla da la sensación de que
las sanciones hicieron fluir el dinero
hacia Rusia como si no hubiera mañana
financiera si le agarra de Ucrania era
pan comido al menos eso es lo que
parecen indicarnos los datos
por ejemplo fijaos que ocurrió en 2022
con el saldo por cuenta corriente de la
balanza de pagos que es donde se mide el
resultado del intercambio de bienes
servicios e inversiones con el
extranjero como podéis comprobar Rusia
tuvo un superávit de casi 250.000
millones de dólares mucho más que el año
anterior de esta forma en apenas unos
pocos meses Rusia pudo compensar cerca
de dos terceras partes de todas las
reservas extranjeras que las potencias
occidentales le congelaron a este país
os acordáis 28 de febrero del 2022 el g7
ha congelado todos los activos de las
reservas rusas en sus países y es que de
hecho todo apunta a que tanto el
petróleo como el gas jugaron un papel
clave en la decisión final de Putin de
invadir Ucrania Por qué pues veréis bajo
la perspectiva del kremlin la enorme
dependencia Europea de los hidrocarburos
rusos haría que la respuesta occidental
fuera muy comedida que es exactamente lo
que ocurrió cuando se anexionó crimea en
el año 2014 y en cualquier caso la su
propia tensión de la Guerra elevaría el
precio de venta de los hidrocarburos lo
que le permitiría al gobierno ruso
financiar sin mayor inconveniente la
Guerra de Ucrania
digamos que la guerra se podría pagar
sola y en cierto modo lo hemos visto eso
es lo que pasó Esta es una de las pocas
veces en toda esta historia que el
cálculo del kremlin Parece que fue
correcto al menos por ahora queridos
amigos amigas Cómo está la economía rusa
Qué perspectivas tiene de cara al futuro
realmente es inmune a las sanciones
occidentales Pues bien veámoslo y lo
primero de todo es empezar la casa por
los cimientos tenemos que saber dónde
estamos exactamente atentos
la cara B de las cuentas rusas
[Música]
lo primero que tenemos que tener
presente para que no los vendan el
pollino es que hablamos de Rusia que no
es el país más transparente ni tiene
precisamente el gobierno más honesto del
mundo en 2022 el kremlin introdujo la
censura estadística una enorme cantidad
de datos como la reservas
internacionales o las métricas
comerciales o de producción dejaron de
estar disponibles también se limitaron
los informes financieros incluso los de
los bancos privados evidentemente a
ningún gobierno le gusta airear datos
que pueden no ir bien y mucho menos a un
gobierno tan autoritario como el de
[Música]
además Los Fuertes controles de
capitales que se han establecido en el
país han hecho que el rublo no refleje
realmente su valor de Mercado Y por qué
es esto importante Pues porque para
valorar el estado Real de la economía
hace falta una tasa de cambio de Mercado
de otra forma el valor Internacional del
pib y su capacidad de compra sea
adultera
por Si eso fuera poco la producción
militar también contribuye positivamente
al pib incluso aunque no valga para nada
Por ejemplo si se producen o buses de
artillería se envían al frente y se
lanzan esos obuses desaparecen pero
quedan incluidos como valor añadido en
el pib Y sí es verdad que es algo que se
ha producido en el año pero es algo que
sin embargo no supone un incremento de
la riqueza nacional más bien todo lo
contrario y sabéis que si algo está
creciendo en Rusia es precisamente el
gasto militar Así que mucho ojo con las
estadísticas rusas y la creatividad Pero
vale Ya sé lo que muchos seguros
estaréis pensando y dale ya están otra
vez los de visualpolitik con la matraca
arremetiendo contra Rusia a base de
cuestionar los datos de este país pues
hombre qué quieres que os diga hablamos
de Rusia lo malo sería no cuestionar sus
datos pero sabéis que incluso dándolos
por buenos las cosas no van tan bien
para el kremlin como muchos piensan
[Música]
primero porque Rusia es un país que
lleva años en declive hablamos de un
país de 143 millones de habitantes cuyo
pib equivale al de Italia y sus
exportaciones a las de Bélgica y eso a
pesar de todo el petróleo el gas y los
demás recursos naturales Pero eso ni
siquiera es todo hablamos de un país muy
envejecido cuya población se ha venido
contrayendo desde la caída de la unión
soviética hablamos de un país que lleva
años en crisis y cuyo nivel de vida se
ha reducido durante la última década
Pues bien Ahora si las sanciones han
hecho algo ha sido precisamente acelerar
esa tendencia por ejemplo fijaos en este
gráfico los datos del fmi y el Banco
Mundial que por otra parte se aproxima
mucho a las propias previsiones del
gobierno ruso son claros clarísimos en
apenas dos años tras la invasión de
Ucrania la economía rusa retrocederá
entre un 5 y un 8%. y ojo porque se
suponía que en 2022 la economía rusa
crecería un 3%, es decir que el daño Ya
causado por las sanciones tras la
invasión de Ucrania es mucho mayor de lo
que a simple vista podemos estar
hablando tranquilamente de un golpe de
entre un 8 y un 12% en dos años podemos
debatir mucho pero este es el coste real
para el nivel de vida de la población
rusa que ya están teniendo las sanciones
y eso a pesar de los precios récord de
la energía
pero es que además Tenemos que tener en
cuenta que las sanciones tenían
fundamentalmente tres objetivos primero
castigar la capacidad productiva de
Rusia a largo plazo para limitar sus
recursos y condenarlo a la relevancia
segundo obstaculizar el esfuerzo de
guerra y dañar la industria militar por
ejemplo impidiendo que puedan
suministrar a sus tropas en el frente
con armas modernas y eficaces y tercero
cortar Los lazos energéticos y
financieros de Rusia con occidente y
sobre todo con Europa y sabéis que esos
tres objetivos en gran medida ya se han
cumplido desde el punto de vista
económico las sanciones están castigando
a Rusia en un próximo vídeo Por cierto
de si lo hubiera sabido os daremos todos
los detalles sobre esta cuestión en
concreto os hablaremos del impacto que
la guerra y las sanciones están teniendo
en el comercio en la industria en la
huida del talento y en la propia
política monetaria del Banco Central
ruso Así que si aún no seguís este canal
no perdáis más tiempo Porque además
habrá sorpresas pronto ya sabéis tenéis
el enlace abajo en la descripción
[Música]
de momento ya os adelanto que el
gobierno de Estados Unidos Espera que el
coste para la economía rusa de las
sanciones en 2030 sea como mínimo del
20% del pib un 20% sobre un país que ya
estaba en declive la diferencia entre
Rusia y los países occidentales no
dejará de crecer primer objetivo
cumplido desde el punto de vista militar
qué queréis que os diga la industria
militar rusa está perdiendo contratos
por todo el mundo y su capacidad para
producir cosas relativamente modernas
está muy mermada de hecho eso es lo que
explica cosas como estas tenemos
informes de los ucranianos de que cuando
encuentran equipos militares rusos están
llenos de semiconductores que sacaron de
lavavajillas y neveras Gina raimondo
secretaria de comercio de los Estados
Unidos
Indonesia compra aviones de combate
estadounidenses y franceses por 22 mil
millones de dólares es un 35 perdió la
partida el cambio de rumbo de Indonesia
que pasar de un acuerdo de Rusia nuevos
acuerdos de compra con Estados Unidos y
Francia pone de relieve La potencia de
las sanciones estadounidenses segundo
objetivo cumplido y En tercer lugar
tanto si hablamos de petróleo como de
gas la ruptura energética de Europa con
Rusia ya es un hecho borre el anuncia la
superación de la dependencia energética
de la Unión Europea hacia Rusia ya lo
veis las sanciones internacionales no
han conseguido parar la Guerra de
Ucrania y tampoco han hecho colapsar la
economía rusa pero mucho ojo con pensar
que no ha servido para nada
[Aplausos]
además fijaos en este gráfico y luego
añadirle la fuga de cerebros la salida
de empresas la huida de capitales o el
aislamiento internacional las cosas en
Rusia amigos no van nada bien pero
sabéis que eso ni siquiera es lo peor lo
peor es lo que puedes dar por llegar
pero está tu atención a esta declaración
con los ingresos astronómicos en
petróleo y gas en general los ingresos
presupuestarios aumentaron solo un 10%,
y los gastos en más del 20 Esto indica
que la situación con las finanzas
públicas está deteriorando y puede
volverse criticar durante el 2023 nikola
y economista y fundador de es beringex
el kremlin obtuvo en 2022 unos ingresos
récord por la venta de hidrocarburos
pese a ello las cuentas públicas han
entrado números rojos de hecho tanto es
así que por ejemplo el gobierno ruso ya
ha empezado a recortar partidas que
hasta hace poco consideraban
estratégicas Por ejemplo si en 2019
habían proyectado invertir
56.800 millones de rublos Hasta el 2024
para el desarrollo de la Inteligencia
artificial ahora los números han
cambiado serán
24.600 millones hasta el año 2030 y la
pregunta es qué puede ocurrir Entonces
si los ingresos extraordinarios del gas
y el petróleo desaparecen pues queridos
amigos amigas mucho ojo porque justo Ahí
es donde ahora están apuntando los
aliados de Ucrania atentos
[Música]
El armagedón energético para Rusia
el gobierno ruso es terriblemente
dependiente de los ingresos del petróleo
y del gas antes de la guerra este sector
generaba casi el 45% de todos los
ingresos del gobierno al tiempo que
generaba todas las Divisas extranjeras
necesarias para cubrir las importaciones
a quien le vendían Pues digamos que
Europa era con mucha diferencia su
principal cliente esta región se tragaba
en torno al 60% de todas las
exportaciones de hidrocarburos de Rusia
Estados Unidos también era un comprador
importante ahora las sanciones han
puesto patas arriba Este mercado
con el paso de los meses Estados Unidos
el Reino Unido la Unión Europea y
algunos otros aliados han prohibido o
comenzado a restringir las importaciones
de petróleo y de gas de Rusia pero desde
luego la medida más contundente llegó en
diciembre de 2022 concretamente el día 5
ese día entró en vigor el tope al precio
del petróleo Ruso y el último mecanismo
ideado por los aliados de Ucrania para
castigar a Rusia exactamente donde más
le duele estos países han dejado o están
dejando en la práctica de comprar
petróleo Ruso y tampoco compras Ya
apenas gas pero eso ni siquiera ha sido
suficiente con el tope el precio del
petróleo ruso le prohíben a cualquier
empresa occidental que preste servicios
en una operación que esté relacionada
con la venta de crudo ruso por encima
del tope fijado de entrada 60 dólares el
barril hablamos de servicios de todo
tipo desde el transporte a los seguros
pasando por la financiación de las
compras
y aún más a comienzos de febrero esta
medida se extenderá a los productos
refinados esto es al Diesel y la
gasolina y la pregunta es cómo están
funcionando todas estas medidas pues
fijaos la prohibición del petróleo de la
Unión Europea y el límite de precios del
petróleo finalmente han entrado en
acción y el impacto están significativo
como se esperaba laury miltta analista
principal de crea el hecho de que los
países occidentales estén dejando de
comprarle petróleo y gas a Rusia ha
hecho que este país tenga que mirar
desesperadamente a otros mercados como
China o la India
El problema es que llevará el petróleo y
el gas a estos países es más caro que
proveerá Europa y además están las
sanciones para cubrirse los compradores
chinos e indios entre otros le están
exigiendo fortísimos descuentos a Rusia
concretamente desde que entró en vigor
el tope al precio del petróleo El crudo
de los urales El crudo de referencia de
Rusia se está vendiendo en el entorno de
los 50 dólares el barril por si fuera
poco las compras de estos países no
están consiguiendo ni de lejos compensar
la pérdida del mercado europeo según los
datos del centro de investigación sobre
energía y aire limpio un zintank con
sede en helsinking en 2023 Rusia puede
perder 280 millones de dólares diarios
como consecuencia del precio del crudo y
sus derivados y ojo que no hablamos de
un futurible poco probable actualmente
Rusia ya estaría perdiendo 172 millones
de dólares cada día hablamos de que en
términos anuales las pérdidas Rusia
pueden rondar los 100.000 millones de
dólares
en esta tabla del propio Ministerio de
Hacienda de Rusia podéis ver cómo
evolucionan aproximadamente los ingresos
del gobierno ante diferentes escenarios
de producción y precio
Es verdad que en el pasado el petróleo
ya ha cotizado a precios de 50 e incluso
40 dólares el barril y Rusia lo ha
soportado y el problema es que existen
dos grandes diferencias por un lado
cuando se vive esa situación el gobierno
recortó el gasto público El problema es
que ahora la Guerra de Ucrania le obliga
a incrementarlo al tiempo que los
ingresos no petroleros también están
cayendo con fuerza Y en segundo lugar
ahora por culpa de las acciones Rusia va
a vender mucho menos al extranjero Así
que mucho ojo con esta especie de trampa
en la que se está metiendo Moscú
Además no sólo hablamos del petróleo lo
mismo ocurre con el gas
pero queréis un dato oficial Pues veréis
en términos de volumen por ejemplo las
ventas internacionales de gas de gasprom
cayeron en 2022 un 46%. la compañía
compensó Esta caída con los mayores
precios pero claro si tenemos en cuenta
los nuevos precios del gas el cañón
presupuestario para Rusia puede ser más
que considerable Rusia sigue siendo una
potencia energética pero su papel ha
cambiado drásticamente Rusia tendrá una
menor cuota de Mercado en petróleo y gas
obtendrá menos beneficios y también ha
perdido parte de su apalancamiento
geopolítico Vladimir mi Love ex
viceministro de energía ruso queridos
amigos amigas Las sanciones quizás no
hayan hecho colapsar la economía rusa
pero han cumplido objetivos muy
importantes que le causarán mucho daño a
Rusia Durante los próximos años además
las nuevas sanciones sobre el petróleo
pueden provocar un escenario económico
mucho más complicado tanto para Rusia
como para el propio kremlin
Putin ha conseguido un tanto personal
pasada la historia como uno de los
líderes rusos que más riqueza destruyó
en menos tiempo por si fuera poco ahora
en Rusia han comenzado a surgir voces en
favor de regresar a la planificación
central y el control del Estado son a
mal decirlo pero en Washington se están
frotando las manos Rusia está perdiendo
en el terreno militar en el terreno
energético y también puede terminar
perdiendo en el terreno económico pero
llegados hasta aquí turno para ti crees
que Rusia podrá soportar las nuevas
sanciones Qué crees Que hará el kremlin
para cambiar el temporal será suficiente
para que estén dispuestos a terminar con
la guerra en Ucrania qué hechas en falta
déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y hablamos debate si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante No
olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribirte a visualpolitik si es que
aún no lo has hecho No me creo que no
hayas hecho aún Muchas gracias por estar
ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]